this episode of real engineering was
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 16,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill the first 500 people a
sign up with the link in the description
will get a 2 month free trial on a cold
and stormy morning in January 1953 the
Princess Victoria Fairy was preparing to
leave its dock in stran WA on the
southwest coast of Scotland
despite gale force warnings an hour into
its journey his captain radioed for help
as the storm forced the ferry on its
side making it impossible to board the
lifeboats of the 176 people aboard the
Princess Victoria only 43 survived but
there was more tragedy to come this
storm was headed south towards the
Netherlands and with the Moon and Sun
causing even higher tides this storm
would severely test the flood defences
of the Netherlands which was still
getting back on its feet after the
Second World War the storm would
ultimately claim the lives of 1835
people in the Netherlands along with 200
thousand cattle and floating 2,000
square kilometres of land destroying
43,000 homes and forcing 72,000 people
to flee today we're going to learn why
this happened and how it sparked the
construction of one of the seven modern
wonders of the world the Dutch Delta
Works after World War 2 the meandering
levees on the coast of the Netherlands
had fallen into disrepair the
Netherlands were just getting back under
their feet after five years of German
occupation just eight years prior to the
storm the poorly maintained flood
defences were a disaster waiting to
happen as the storm approached it forced
water inland with nowhere to go but up
this put intense pressure on the dikes
and levees of the Low Countries and by
storms end 139 km/h open with nearly 26%
of the Netherlands land area being under
sea level sea water bursts through these
breaches with a man's strength causing
damage that would take decades to repair
and would spur the formation of the
Delta committee just 20 days later to
ensure this could never happen again and
this is what they came up with the new
Delta plan would shorten the Dutch
coastline by 700 kilometers by closing
the primary inlets in these four
locations this would drastically reduce
the length of levees and dikes that
needed to be inspected and maintained
and thus decreasing the chances of weak
points jeopardizing the safety of the
Dutch people however this was no easy
task and what
with an enormous cost before these works
could be completed additional barriers
needed to be erected upstream to improve
fresh and salt water management and
prevent fresh water emptying from the
Rhine muse and shelled river from
redirecting around these new Dobbs the
northernmost closure dam also needed to
be equipped with a hydraulic sluice
capable of dealing with the output of
the Rhine River as this freshwater would
flood the Netherlands from the other
direction if it was prevented from
emptying into the North Sea on top of
all this a number of ports such as the
Port of Rotterdam and the Port of
Antwerp had to stay accessible so aside
from the fixed dams bridges and sluices
to new locks that would allow an inland
ship route between Antwerp and Rotterdam
needed to be built amazingly on top of
all this work the Dutch still managed to
consider the environmental impact of
this work the largest of the structures
built for the Delta Works project the
austere shelled storm surge barrier was
originally planned to completely close
the mouth of this River which would
create a freshwater basin however
resistance to this plan arose as it
would completely change the saltwater
environment of the area the austere
shelled scenery is unique with a great
variety of fish water plants and animals
so in 1976 the Dutch government agreed
to a different plan building an open
barrier that could be closed during
heavy storms and high tides adding
another 2.5 billion euros to the cost of
the project this barrier is nine
kilometres long with 62 openings
each 40 metres wide allowing the tidal
movement to remain intact
to build a structure this massive that
needs to not only support its own weight
but the enormous force of a storm surge
pushing against it would require
extensive foundations the first part of
these foundations were created by
forming two islands the biggest of which
housing aloft to allow ships to pass
through the barrier this island even
included a massive dry dock to construct
the 65 pylons needed to support the
sluice gates each using 7,000 cubic
metres of concrete and taking one and a
half years to build between each Island
a trench was dug on both sides of the
trench mats were placed to keep the
seabed in place while specially built
ships were then used to consolidate the
sand at the bottom of the French using
special vibrating needles the Sun would
be vibrated to pack the Sun firmly
together creating a surface that could
carry the weight of the massive
the trench itself was then covered with
specially made mats filled with rocks to
prevent erosion of the underlying sand
the pylons were left hollow so they
could be picked up by another
purpose-built you shaped ship and moved
into place there inside of the trench on
top of the mats they would be lowered
filled with sand and closed with
concrete the wide foot of each pylon was
packed in stone as it is vital the
pylons never moved because of even one
of the massive 262 480 tonne doors
cannot move the current in that location
could become enormous and potentially
damaged the structure finally these
enormous hydraulic pistons were attached
to the sluice gates allowing three
kilometres of the nine kilometer long
storm surge barrier to open and close on
demand this project truly is one of the
modern wonders of the world allowing the
Dutch to rule the tide and ensure the
chances of another devastating flood are
dramatically reduced the boat would sea
levels continuing to rise in warmer seas
causing even stronger storms we need to
remind ourselves of the lessons learned
here the flooding of New Orleans in 2005
occurred for many of the same reasons as
the 1953 flooding of the Netherlands
poorly maintained levees broke well
below their design tolerances allowing
80% of the city to be flooded in just
five hours had New Orleans taken lessons
from history and reduced the length of
the defences needed as they have done
now with a 1.1 billion dollar Lake
Borgne surge barrier and they may have
saved over 1,000 people and prevented
the 108 billion dollars of damage to
storm cost if these trends continue
cities around the world are going to
have to seriously assess the risk of
flooding and make plans to prevent any
chance of a flood taking the lives of
their citizens so you may have admired
some of the footage in this video it's
not the first time I've traveled to
location to get footage but it is the
first time I felt really prepared
because I finally learned the necessary
skills to use my equipment like a
professional from Skillshare I learned
all the technical terms and settings to
set up my still shots of the storm surge
barrier I learned how to get cinematic
shots with my drone and I learned how to
apply the correct color correction to
Skillshare is simply the best place on
the internet to learn creative skills
that could help you develop a new life
skill with professional and
understandable classes that follow a
clear learning curve you could even
learn the skills to start a new business
like I did with this channel through
courses for animation and editing a
premium membership starts around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses
but the first 500 people to sign up with
this link will get a two month free
trial in those two months you could
easily learn the skills you need to
start a new hobby or business so ask
yourself right now what skill have you
been putting off learning what project
have you been dreaming of completing but
you aren't sure if you have the skills
to do it
why not start right now and sign up the
skill share using the link below you've
nothing to lose on a valuable life skill
to gain as usual thank you for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters for helping this channel
exist if you'd like to see more from me
or see more content from real
engineering like sneak peeks for
upcoming videos check out the links from
my Instagram Twitter and Facebook
accounts in the description
[Music]